Dave Springer:
My name is Dave Springer, graduate of 1984.
I was a point guard, off guard.
Played two years for Bill Morse and then my
last two years, junior and senior year, I
played for Coach Rod Halstead.
I went to high school at Crestview High School
in Convoy, Ohio, and I really owe my opportunity
to come to Hillsdale to my high school coach,
Ray Etzler.
I was a small town kid that had aspirations
to play college basketball and Coach Etzler
sent some letters out.
Got an invite from the coach to come up here
for a visit and he said, "Throw in your gym
clothes."
I'll never forget the legendary athletic director
here, Jack McAvoy, who is a highly respected
man.
He sent me down and he said, "Now, David,
as you go through this visit, they're going
to wine and dine and be really nice to you.
Make sure you take the time to talk to some
people about Hillsdale."
I really learned a lot more about Hillsdale.
Never regretted it.
Personally, I feel I played on two of the
best teams that Hillsdale has ever had.
My freshman year and senior year, I could
go on and on with a lot of guys.
They're wonderful friends and they were wonderful
players.
My freshman year, we were fourth in the nation,
so I was fortunate enough to be third team
All American, and I was player of the year
in the GLIAC.
There is no way that would've happened without
those guys.
If I'm not on two very successful teams, it
doesn't happen I'm not here talking to you
today.
When you get my age, you learn not to take
anything for granted.
I think you look back and how blessed you
were.
Those are special, special times here at Hillsdale.
The games were great and the basketball was
great, but it was more about sharing the ups
and downs.
When you're in college, those are major decisions.
Take a job, you're going to fall in love,
you're going to get married, whatever, but
you share those with your college friends.
That means more to me than the basketball
part of it.
Appreciated the opportunity, had a lot of
fun competing.
Boy, the people part of it means more to me
now by far.
I am very humbled and very touched by the
whole thing.